[Music]
medical shows are of course a staple of
television dramas I mean we love to
watch actors struggle with all that
doctors speak and pretend to save lives
but did you know that sometimes the
stars actually take what they've learned
and help people in real life listen to
these stories
we don't just entertain Clemens I saw
this person fall like that I feel like I
could be more of a help in an emergency
than if I had never taken this job
watching Taylor Kinney as a first
responder on Chicago Fire makes you
think yeah that's the guy you want
around in the real life crisis after all
he's had some training and we did maybe
two weeks at the Fire Academy in Chicago
where they trained the actual
firefighters who save
she's totally being modest the night
shift Jill Flint wasn't acting when she
came to the rescue of a fellow party
going
someone had too much on New Year's Eve
they consumed too much and they fell
over
passed out completely hit their head and
I'm spy the EMTs to come and get them
out now he's crashing
we got to open him up right here skim
down learning's like CPR yeah I'm liking
how to deal with a wound you've learned
you like how to position that person
another life I'll be a doctor possibly
Nigel forecasting Hank call toxicology
and we'd make an appointment with dr.
Delphis the Chicago med star heard the
sound of screeching tires followed by a
car crash the quick-thinking TV dog was
first on the scene
pulling the driver to safety I jumped
into this 12-foot construction pit and
started climbing up the side of the car
to open the door this girl scurried out
and in that moment I started looking her
over like I would on the show when a
patient comes in and as I'm helping her
now and she was
you're from that show I'm like yeah yeah
I'm from the show but not everybody's a
willing patient by all this this is the
site dad you're not a real doctor no you
can't sit right winter up I think even
as a fake doctor I'm capable of that and
if you think that's bad Scott told us
that he sometimes gets even more carried
away and tries to diagnose his families
leave it to the real dollars
[Music]
you